US President Barack Obama's oldest daughter Malia...
...will begin studying at Harvard University in 2017.
Malia will join a long line of presidents' children...
...who have studied at the elite group of universities known as the Ivy League.
So, what is the appeal of an Ivy League education and why are these schools so powerful?
Well, the Ivy League is synonymous with elitism and prestige,...
...and its schools are generally regarded as some of the best in the world.
The origin of "Ivy League" is still a matter of debate.
However, one theory attributes the name to the Roman numeral for "four" or "IV,"...
...which represents the original four institutions.
Today, the official Ivy League encompasses eight private universities...
...in the Northeast United States.
Although their reputations and rankings vary,...
...Ivy League schools are collectively known for having high tuition,...
...demanding curriculum, slim acceptance rates,...
...and enormous financial endowments.